This ellipse would be centered at the origin and it would have an a value of 6
and it would have a b value of 4. Great thinking if you got each of these
correct. We know the center is 0,0 since this fits the general formula for our
ellipse. There's no number next to the x inside parenthesis and there's no
number next to the y inside our parenthesis. So we know our ellipse is centered
at 0, 0. To find the a value we want to take the square root of this
denominator of 36. And the square root of 36 equals 6 which means we go 6 units
in the left direction and in the right direction. Remember the a term indicated
which way we move in the x direction. Since the a number is directly underneath
the x squared term. For b, we just need to take the square root of 16, which
equals 4. So, to get two other points on our ellipse, we move 4 units up from
the center, and 4 units down from the center. This gives us four easily
identifiable points, and we can connect our ellipse. Remember that this was our
general formula for an ellipse centered at the origin. So we need to find the
square root of 36 and the square root of 16. I think it's always more helpful
to write these as perfect squares if you can. Comparing the equations like
this, we can quickly see that the value of a equals 6 and the value of b equals
4.